now turning to weather people in the
deep south are cleaning up this morning
after the latest outbreak of flooding
heavy rain left a large area of central
mississippi under water yesterday there
were more than 100 rescues in and around
jackson the state capital this storm
system has been dumping heavy rain for
the last four days since it formed over
texas on sunday night the national
weather service predicts the storm
threat will linger for the rest of the
week justin michaels with our partners
at the weather channel is in hard hit
brandon mississippi justin good morning
nate good morning to you that's right
the rain came down fast and hard here
this is now the wettest august on record
in jackson mississippi and this area is
just the latest to deal with historic
flooding this month alone
one by one these toddlers were gently
placed on the back of this truck
they and adults more than 100 in all
rescued from the flood waters that
rushed into their daycare center in
rankin county mississippi wednesday
in brandon firefighters and sheriff's
deputies waded through knee-high water
to rescue trapped seniors inside their
living facility
other communities weren't spared either
as residents escaped to higher ground
navigating inundated streets as their
homes and cars sat under water this area
is not known for flooding so i don't we
don't have flood insurance i don't think
anybody has flood insurance dave and
ovis crum recently moved into this house
our house burned march the first and we
lost everything
so we bought this house and now it's
flooded
the storms are part of a system that
have slammed the south first hitting
north texas where almost a foot of rain
landed on dallas the floods there
killing one woman
so this system is continuing to move
east of course a tough road for the
folks who live here in the south a long
road to recovery in fact and also jamie
the best advice we can give turn around
don't drown if you come across those
floodwaters and make sure you're just
taking care of each other this is a
tough go for people here jamie into you
that's great advice justin michaels
thank you